what do you learn from just experiencing
a person like that
you learn that you have to love it to do
it i mean here he was 90 he was taking
naps between
shots sometimes he would nod off in his
chair and someone would gently wake him
up but once you woke him up you couldn't
stop him oh my god
ed joins fellow all-stars like tracee
ellis ross and daniel day kim for the
anthology series that premieres tonight
on fx i really believe in my bones that
black lives matter they do five
standalone episodes tackle big issues
combined with bj's sense of humor and
the same unique pov he brought to the
office that's just sex right this tape
is unequivocal evidence that the police
lie about this incident ben platt
playing a guy who finds a police
incident in the back of his sex tapes
john bernthal playing someone who lost
his daughter and and has a revenge plot
i wanted to sort of take the things that
we're all talking about but tell them
with some comedy and with some drama
anybody you'd like to see paul you'd
like to pull in from the office to
season two of this show the premise oh
everybody back to work
still waiting on that coffee of course
at all i always love to reunite with
steve corral and of course mindy kaling
i'd love to someday do something
something with her but we're worried
that it would we'd fight too much
have you heard any rumblings of a
possibility of us getting you guys back
together i feel it's a little soon you
never know what you have till it's gone
well while we wait for that office
reboot there's more new tv to watch we
have your exclusive preview of the show
that's being called game of thrones in
space foundation which debuts september
24th on apple tv plus stars harry
potter's alfred enoch all grown up and
madmen's jared harris hoping to save
civilization it's epic it's epic in its
ambition it's a thousand year tale
change is frightening especially to
those in power
[Music]